The Magicians do you have a favorite
moment from filming that series and by
the way was there a lot of drama on that
series I didn't have a lot of drama I
actually see a lot of drama I had a
wonderful time
you looked at me like holy [ __ ] I mean
the show's over now you know the show's
over
um I I think I came into a already
I came into a a steam train already like
in full motion if that makes sense so
when I came set I I had a lovely time
like I had a lovely time everyone every
customer was lovely to me
um whether people have like you know
quorums or something or favorites or
whatnot
um I've noticed that for me
if it doesn't uh and tell anything to do
with me like it's like oh well then you
know it's fine as long as it doesn't
affect me but that being said that
sounds terrible no because the first
person I met on set was hail and Hale
and I are friends to this I call them
he's a nice guy super nice guy uh we
just we just gelled well you know and uh
summer was a second person and to this
days talk to Summer
um and everyone I met has been lovely
um and lovely to me and they've had a
great you know I think it's hard because
they're all in the same age range and um
I think there's discrepancies of like
um tears you know like who like me who's
the lead who's not and that's such an
ensemble show but there is leads you
know right and there is leads and
whatnot but uh they made me feel
comfortable and that's all I can say is
they made me always feel comfortable
okay um but I would hear as any set you
know I think always but uh uh but yeah
what do you expect with just a castle it
was a little talented there was a little
kid they're all talented they're all
young they're all beautiful lovely you
know there's bound to be a little bit
bit of Sparks or not or negativity or
whatnot in there that's all you'll say
that's all I say do you have a favorite
moment from filming that series
um I did love shooting on the moonshot
the the boat the um it was really sad to
see the way the character for my
character the the way they kind of um
wrap their their human life form uh
because in the book he dies very
differently and then the series
um we've dealt with something really
serious which is depression and he had
this key that kind of um this wonderful
uh character that seems so bubbly and on
point and always structured was holding
a deep secret which was depression and
uh when the truth came out um he jumped
off the ship and a dragon comes out and
eats him and when you go through the
belly of a dragon which is played by the
Creator Sarah
um her voice anyways uh you go through
purgatory and so you're not dead you're
in purgatory which is nice because they
saved him and then brought him back for
his future Seasons but I that episode
was really special because I was like I
hope people you know this starts a
conversation about checking with your
friends yeah yeah
foreign